hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
wir heute zu ching ching ching ching
ching das beste spiel aller zeiten
die spielleute das spiel kehrt mario wir
sehen hier schon mit dem ersten level
ich weiß jetzt dass schon mal gespielt
und er weiß schon viel weiter bei dem
spiel geht es darum das ganze war die so
ist wie super mario nur ein bis sie mit
beschützen steuerung die mit witali die
rumlaufen töten und können wir 27 gegen
springe ich dachte wären drin
da spielt mit den heimtückisch also
teilweise zerstören wie irgendwelche
sachen da kommen dann aber plötzlich
irgendwelche gegner raus wir haben hier
guckt da kommt der gegner aus was ist
überall gegner ein super mario kommt da
oben in dem ersten level eigentlich
immer irgendwie ein bild das man mit dem
wetter vorankommt meinem ausstieg an
zeit im bild sehr gut luca wir versuchen
einfach mal ein paar level hier zu
schaffen
[Musik]
wir probieren wieder von vorne
jetzt würden wir das i-phone eigentlich
keine richtigen items grinsen wenn wir
vorne lang laufen sehen wir schon da
kommt ein gegner rausspringen hierbei
die röhre und jetzt wissen wir ja dass
hier vorne ein riesiges fahrzeit wg
[Musik]
tut mir leid falls man mikrometern
übersteuert aber bei mir drehen die
emotionen durch bei sonne spielt da
sehen wir die kluge idee spielt mal
wieder
ich habe keine ahnung wie ich das jetzt
hier machen soll also ich versuche jetzt
einfach mal im hohen bogen das hat
geklappt wenn ich hier drauf drücken wir
schon okay da haben wir jetzt
[Musik]
als sie da gerade gegen gesprungen war
als ich da gerade gegen gesprungen bin
hatte ich schon gesehen dass da von pilz
rauskamen da dachte ich okay ich gehe
mal unter du kleine bin ich hier lang
laufen fällt das hier runter und jetzt
versuche ich mal den hut zu kriegen
das ist jetzt passiert ich seh schon
wieder kommen freunde ich bin hier rüber
und da passiert irgendwas deswegen gehe
ich jetzt mal hier so ein bisschen in
anderen weg und gema hier oben lang
versucht man hier oben lang zu kommen
genau jetzt bin ich hier unten was
willst du entweder missgeburt davor dass
der jackpot oh mein gott freunde kennen
ich hab den checkpoint als nächstes mal
wenn ich hier einsteigen komme ich quasi
hier wieder raus ich bringe gegen einen
stern
[Musik]
also hier unter mir kommen
jahren raus will ich am besten nicht
gegen springen dann springt man hier
gegen der komplimente raus wer vertraut
springe
das ist einfach vor allen dingen wie bei
mario also hier dazu bringt auf jeden
fall runter darf ich auf jeden fall
nicht hindert nicht bringen dass man
hier einen kleinen weg wird und weiter
ich sage euch freunde ich stehe hier an
diesem berg und ich muss über dieses
loch zu bringen und ich danke euch egal
was ich mache da plötzlich was geschafft
keine falle ein paar sekunden später ist
der
ernst hier wieder einfach über alles
drüber springen was irgendwie gibt hier
vorne oben direkt drauf da war zumindest
hier war direkt nix und jetzt weiß ich
dass ich hier direkt raus springt ihr
rüber springen auf die ablage die wolke
einfach hier hoch über hier hoch über
direkt auf direkte dort hier oben drauf
dann hier auf die ablage drauf springen
dann hier am besten direkt auf dich doch
ich bin jetzt übrigens von -6 leben wie
wir hier eingeblendet wenn aber freunde
ich habe ein gutes gefühl ich glaube
dass wir die wirklich schaffen können
also hier vorne drauf ganz locker
vorgehen hier vorne drauf hierunter kann
ich auch noch gehen da kommen wir ja nie
wie jetzt hiob die röhre hier oben drauf
da passiert zumindest die wolke jetzt
würde das heißt die dort wird einfach
mal hier runter und wir sehen schon
jetzt bin ich hier und jetzt so gewesen
wie auch die röhre dann hier von der
röhre hier wieder runter dann hier
hinlaufen und warten mit diesen kräften
teile darunter kommen und jetzt wenn der
typ kommen
[Musik]
sie bietet mario also hier springt einer
durch also gut gemacht
am ende springt rüber what you here is
the only thing you fiel klar ich kann
das spiel schon trucks flieger alter
[Musik]
zeit immer noch das verdammte erste
level bei dem ich hier gerade stehen
bleiben also es ist jetzt nicht
irgendwie dass ich hier im dritten oder
vierten level bin oder so aber ich bin
jetzt wieder hier angekommen und jetzt
muss ich auf jeden fall erstmal hier
hoch und jetzt mit an schwung über die
flagge der übergesprungen
jetzt bin ich hier und jetzt muss ich
nämlich hier wieder die nein nein nein
ich bin zu weit gesprungen freunde
ich verstehe diese land kag nicht alter
das kann doch nicht wahr sein ich
versuche die ganze zeit auf penibelst
art und weise also antworten wie möglich
irgendwie zu schaffen aber es ist
einfach hier unmöglich also ich bin ja
hoch jetzt muss ich diese plattform hier
muss ich irgendwie abwerten sorgen heute
nicht hier springe ich hier über nicht
so weit sondern genau hierhin jetzt auf
die plaques und la mitgebracht oder ende
tötet wenig das hat natürlich jetzt
hallo jetzt jeder zweite level
freigeschaltet das heißt wir kriegen
einfach mal drauf wir sind bei -15 leben
laufe ich einfach mal vor in die röhre
reihen und sehen schon dass wir hier
sind wir wieder gestorben in die röhre
dürfen also nicht rein erteilt sich
einfach mal oben darf dann scheint auch
nicht rein
ich weiß nicht was ich sonst machen soll
also ich gehe hier hin da kommt ne ich
geh jetzt mal zu dem pilz hier den tod
also noch heute kann ich nicht ich kann
ich nicht hoch bringe ich kann ich auch
die linke weiter wenn ich in die röhre
reihen dir passiert nichts gekommen die
der pilz raus was passiert wenn ich
jetzt in die röhre reingehe
[Musik]
also irgendwie wohl unsichtbare blöcke
die ich irgendwie aktivieren muss indem
ich dagegen springe ich weiß allerdings
nicht genau wo diese blöcke versteck
finden wenn ich hier bin und einfach mal
hoch hüpfte den wir schon hier ist auf
jeden fall nicht hinter wenn ich hier
bin und einfach mal hoch ist die auch
nicht zentral hier ist auch nichts
dergleichen wenn ich irgendwo hoch sind
ja auch keine blöcke ok irgendwie habe
ich das recht jetzt auch noch im block
aktiviert ich weiß nicht was passiert
wenn ich da jetzt drauf springe dann
hoch springen ist hier dass ich gar
nichts sehr gut auf jeden fall
[Musik]
2000 jahre später also eher dazu gemacht
hat er hier entgegen gesprungen ist dann
hat er den geist rausgelassen dann
springt er dort oben gegen holt den pilz
raus und dann geht da rein
das probiere jetzt auch also erstmal
hier den block rausholen an den geist
rauslassen jetzt diesem bild frau
platten und jetzt schneller geschafft
jetzt bin ich hier unten angekommen ich
probier mal hier oben drauf zu springen
probier mal hier rein zu gehen hier
drauf jetzt erst recht wenn ich das
ganze wieder von vorne machen muss dann
okay ich bin jetzt auf jeden fall mal
wieder hier er mich weit hinten hin
komme jetzt muss ich auf jeden fall hier
mal rüber springen hier auch dinge kann
ich mal drauf gehen und hier allemal
töten ok sehr gute entscheidung luca zum
glück sei kein panzer in der mitte eine
[Musik]
hohe konzentration ich fahre hier runter
die direkt auf diese teile drauf jetzt
einen weiterspringen nämlich hier
[Musik]
doch genau hier auf die teile drauf
jetzt ein ganz bekannter spruch an der
stelle muss ich jetzt wirklich sagen
erschweren kann ich mich normalerweise
eher weniger jetzt kann doch nicht so
schwer werden von hier direkt auf dieses
ding aufzuspringen genau jetzt direkt
hier wieder drauf ihnen hier drauf und
jetzt den hierüber schicken so dass
diejenigen teile töte direkt einen
straighten roger moore über hier drauf
ganz vorsichtig hier komplett rüber
jetzt jochen style drauf springen den
ich jetzt als plattform ihn als enkel
soll ja
[Musik]
freunde ein letzter 34 schön runter
jetzt auf diese vier fragezeichen hier
drauf mit den an schwung nehmen und
rüber springen auf den hohen jetzt rüber
auf den anderen hohen in hier vorne
töten so dafür die teile da hinten
abgeknallt genau jetzt ich habe ihn
nicht berührt dass sich als versuch an
hier also schön runter hier auf die vier
fragezeichen 3 wird weiterhin einen lang
auf den hohen hier jetzt einen lang
weiter auf den anderen hohen hier wieder
drauf und jetzt ihn hier berühren so
dass er die anderen kleinen langsam
rüber auf ihn hier vorne und jetzt rüber
gesamt auf ihn hier hier muss ich dieses
ding aktivieren oder das teil kann ich
jetzt glaube ich von oben auch wieder
töten genau jetzt eine ganz ganz lange
klappe weil die alle hier über genug bin
ich hier und jetzt checkpoint meine
damen und herren checkt man habe ich
erreicht ich seh schon komme ich bringe
darüber hier passiert wieder irgendwas
ich bin gott ich wusste hier muss ich
irgendwie so vorgehen dass ich den hier
runter fallen lasse dann ihnen hier und
jetzt muss ich ganz klar übers es war
klar wenn ich früher schon los bringen
und jetzt hier über genau jetzt habe ich
so geschafft bin hier vorne angekommen
ein werk stern alter tötet mich immer
wieder bitte kommt nicht rüber bitte
kommt rüber zu mir okay alles genau
gerade wieder unten ja abwarten bis er
an der weitere genau jetzt ich habe ihn
nicht berührt der letzten versuch
freunde hier hoch ihr könnt jetzt in
einen kanal abonnieren oder jung
einem staubecken ihr plädiert für andere
medien und berlin einbrechen doch die
glocke kriegen wir kommentieren
richtungen
[Musik]